this video was made possible by
brilliant start learning with brilliant
for 20
off by being one of the first 200 people
to sign up at brilliant.org
wendover this is east asia comprised of
china japan korea and taiwan
and this is europe 2.4 billion people
live in these two areas
a third of the world's population more
impressively
each of these two areas have a gdp of
around 20 trillion dollars
combined just these countries account
for half
of the world's economic activity they
are two of the world's most
dense most developed and most
economically
interlinked regions and are home to the
world's largest and most influential
cities
yet laying between them is just one
country
russia this more or less means that one
country controls whether europe can get
to asia and vice versa
and for a while they couldn't during the
cold war
almost universally non-soviet airlines
were not allowed to fly over the soviet
union this proved a huge barrier to
travel
in the 1950s flying on boac which later
became british airways
the fastest route from london to tokyo
involved leaving london at 10 am on
friday
and stopping in rome beirut bahrain
karachi
calcutta yangon bangkok and manila
before finally arriving in tokyo
at 6 a.m on a sunday all in all that was
36 hours
and 10 000 miles of travel to get
between two cities
six thousand miles apart and that was
also their fastest service on the comet
jet plane
their slower and cheaper propeller
service would leave london on a sunday
and not arrive in tokyo until thursday
after
88 hours of travel it was just hugely
inefficient
but there was a better way over the
arctic
sas was the first to develop routes
overflying the arctic
but other airlines soon followed these
routes were first used to get to the
american west coast faster
this involves developing new navigation
systems to overcome the issue of
traditional magnetic compasses not
working properly in the high north
in the 1950s no commercial airplane had
the range to fly to the american west
coast
non-stop but with sas's new polar route
they would take a relatively quick route
from copenhagen stopping in kangaroo
suart greenland and winnipeg canada
before arriving in los angeles this cut
what was previously a 36 hour trip
down to 22. with sas having proven that
commercial flights over the arctic were
both safe and commercially viable
other airlines quickly followed not only
setting up routes to the american west
coast
but also to the far east the most direct
route from london to tokyo flies over
siberia but since that airspace was
closed
airlines chose another way the other way
around the world
in the 1960s only 40 000 people lived in
anchorage alaska
and alaska had just become a state the
year before but its airport emerged as a
crucial stopping point between europe
and asia boac's thrice weekly polar
route from london to tokyo would leave
heathrow at 1 45 pm
arrive in anchorage nine and a half
hours later stop for an hour to refuel
and then fly the remaining seven hours
to tokyo all in all it was timetabled to
take
only 17 and a half hours half of what
the trip took before
it was as drastic a reduction in travel
time as when concord cut new york to
london flights from 6 hours to 3.
boac wasn't the only one all the major
european carriers set up routes to the
far east
via anchorage in the 1960s and 70s while
anchorage sees only a few dozen daily
commercial flights mostly to the
continental us today
in the 1970s it was served by air france
sas
klm iberia lufthansa japan airlines
korean
air and more this tiny town in alaska
quickly became one of the most connected
and cosmopolitan
areas of the world with passengers and
flight crews from
all around the world stopping over all
because of where
it was as aircraft became more advanced
with longer range there were a few
airlines that managed to avoid stopping
in anchorage on their way from europe to
east asia
fener for example started flying from
helsinki to tokyo non-stop
in 1983 by flying an international
airspace
north of russia over the north pole this
made what is today a nine-hour flight
13 hours but it was still faster than
stopping in
anchorage overwhelmingly though airlines
continued to fly through anchorage
eventually though the soviet union did
of course fall in 1991
and with that russia started to grant
overflight rights to european and east
asian airlines
they first had to modernize and
anglicize their air traffic control
system
all international pilots and air traffic
controllers worldwide speak english
but before since there were few
international flights over russia
the russian air traffic controllers
didn't speak english once the changes
were made
airlines quickly switched to flying
non-stop from europe to asia
over siberia that left anchorage largely
deserted
the airport built a large and modern
international terminal in 1982 to handle
all the traffic passing through the
airport
but then less than 10 years later all
those airlines that kept the airport
busy
left in droves today that international
terminal
built to handle hundreds of flights per
month only sees a flight
every few days russia meanwhile is
prospering thanks to the opening up of
its airspace
flying to asia over siberia saves
airlines huge amounts of time and money
so russia therefore charges airlines
huge amounts of money to do so
exact numbers vary by airline and are
kept secret but for each round-trip
flight between europe and asia
siberian overflight fees are believed to
account for up to
100 of a single passenger's ticket price
russia has an enormous amount of power
by controlling this airspace
and they use it to their advantage 133
countries have signed the international
civil aviation organization's transit
agreement
which essentially allows any airline
from any country to fly through the
signatories airspace but russia however
has not so they can pick and choose
which countries airlines get to fly
through their airspace
the country can and has used its
airspace as a geopolitical weapon
in 2014 they threatened to shut down
their airspace to european union
airlines in response to sanctions
in 2017 they threatened to close their
airspace to dutch airlines in response
to a reduction in landing slots for a
russian airline at schiphol airport
and in april 2018 they tacitly
threatened to close their airspace to
u.s airlines in response to u.s military
action in syria
but russia not only decides which
countries can fly in its airspace
it also decides which specific airlines
there is more or less a rule that only
one
airline per european country can overfly
russia there are
certainly exceptions both british
airways and virgin atlantic are
london-based for example but both
overfly siberia on their routes to
shanghai and hong kong but air france is
the only french airline with siberian
overflight rights
lufthansa is the only german airline
with overflight rights iberia is the
only spanish airline with overflight
rights
and so on and so forth for the longest
while this wasn't a problem
european countries aren't that big and
few had more than one
intercontinental airline but nowadays
however that's changing
we're seeing more and more budget
airlines competing with the large
established carriers on long-haul routes
but with this system of overflight
permissions
the legacy carriers more or less have a
monopoly on east asian routes
sas for example operates out of norway
denmark and sweden
and they have siberian overflight rights
that take them to destinations like
tokyo beijing and shanghai
sas is therefore the only scandinavian
airline allowed to overfly siberia
but also in scandinavia is norwegian air
as one of the largest low-cost airlines
in the world
norwegian has pioneered long-haul budget
flying mainly focusing on flights from
major european cities to the u.s
the airline has said though that it
wants to expand eastwards
they already have flights from
copenhagen oslo and stockholm to bangkok
and from london to singapore
but these destinations are far enough
south that they don't involve flying
over siberia
the airline has repeatedly applied for
siberian overflight rights and
repeatedly been denied
they argue that sas does not operate any
flight from norway to asia so they
should be granted permission as the only
norwegian airline
but since sas is partially registered in
norway
russia isn't granting permission
norwegian does have a subsidiary legally
registered in the uk
but it's unlikely that russia would
grant overflight rights to this
since british airways and virgin
atlantic also have overflight rights
norwegian airlines also has a subsidiary
based in ireland which does not have an
airline with siberian overflight rights
but sas also has a subsidiary base in
the country
which could mean that russia will deny
rights to this subsidiary too
as of now russia has not granted
overflight permission to
any budget airline others have tried
icelandic airlines wow air and iceland
air have attempted to negotiate
overflight rights
but russia views overflights as a way to
make money and wants to charge fees that
would make it
impossible for a low cost airline for
now
wow air has planned to start flights
from reykjavik to delhi india
which in a direct routing would fly over
russia but can route around russia by
only adding 45 minutes in extra flight
time if an arrangement isn't made before
flight start in december 2018.
russia is a powerful politically savvy
country that knows that these overflight
rights are a huge negotiation tool
pulling the rights of a country's
airline would be a huge financial blow
and granting rights is also a huge
advantage competition though
is good for the consumer and this
current system stifles it
until russia starts granting overflight
rights to budget airlines
non-stop flights to asia will stay
expensive the fact that this shortcut
over siberia is now open at all however
saves millions of passengers yearly
enormous amounts
of time and money watching this 10
minute video of our technological
progress
might make you think that we got here in
one giant leap but that of course
is not the case we had to develop new
navigation systems to work around old
school compasses
build airports to help planes refuel and
extend the range of aircraft
the problem of advancing enough to be
able to fly non-stop to the other side
of the world was huge
but it was broken down and approached in
small steps brilliant works in a similar
way
breaking a problem down identifying the
relevant concepts thinking clearly
through each part and building it back
up to the conclusion in this manner
super complex topics like number theory
or calculus can be easily understood
by anyone my favorite from brilliant is
their logic course which starts simple
but then builds up your skills so you
can solve seemingly impossible problems
to support wendover productions and
learn more about brilliant go to
brilliant.org
wendover and sign up for free and also
the first 200 people that go to that
link will get 20
off the annual premium subscription
thanks for watching and we'll see you
again in three weeks for another
wendover productions video
you